this is max also known as rinharisaki
and he's our in-house breath of the wild
expert today he's back to react and
break down more ridiculous
clips if you have any suggestions for
max or other future videos make sure to
drop them in the comments below
all right take it away max
[Music]
awesome so yeah it looks like uh paradox
guardian here is having a small scuffle
with the lynel
nothing too crazy in the beginning it's
just you know parries and stuff but uh
obviously the interesting part is the
boomerang where he throws it and as he's
returning
he's in the middle of a flurry rush and
picks it up while he's in slow-mo
and attacks with the boomerang it's
mostly about timing because
obviously you know lynels have different
patterns and different attacks so
he just happened to you know run away
and come back and that was the perfect
timing for that boomerang to return but
obviously it just looks really cool
because you're in slo-mo and you pick up
a mooring mid-air while you're slow-mo
and then you attack them with it so
yeah it's obviously just another neat
looking trick you can do breath of the
wild
i both spin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
money
huh
[Music]
let's start from the very beginning here
stasis launching pretty
common technique uh one of the first
launch techniques ever found in breath
of the wild
it's pretty ancient now there's a lot of
better ways to get around to different
places but
nonetheless obviously it looks really
cool so uh basically
you're storing up the energy from a tree
or any object
and then hitting yourself with it while
you're in midair to launch yourself
what's interesting about this
hitting obviously is he's on top of it
and normally if he was just normally
spinning with that axe
he would just spin around a circle and
nothing would happen he wouldn't hit the
tree but he's doing a technique called
bow spinning which i coined
um which is basically putting the weapon
onto your back
and making that the hitbox so basically
now
that axe is hitting from your backside
and that is a vertical hitbox so that'll
hit
things above you and below you now he's
storing up the energy
for the the stasis launch through the
bow spin so
after that he does the stasis launch
knocks over to the
labyrinth and then he does um another
technique uh called a skew clip
another famous technique in speedrunning
because this lets you
just literally phase through walls i'm
not gonna go into the very specifics of
how it works
again because it's very complicated but
in short
by hitting your shield on a angled
surface
while you're shield surfing that will
save link's position in strange ways
so that'll cause link to pivot
aggressively in different directions and
you can use this to force yourself into
a wall
so he must have he must have saved the
skew before
this clip was made and then saved it
specifically for this wall because
different skews work in different angles
and different directions he skews
through the wall skews to another wall
to get inside of the dungeon
and then he grabs a medallion so this is
just a neat way to obviously
you know skip the whole getting lost in
the labyrinth and all that this is just
a way to just go
straight to the medallion you don't have
to worry about all the guardians and
stuff in the way
[Music]
[Music]
all right a little more a little more
humor added um
i haven't seen this stuff in a long long
time either so what he must have done
here initially he must have used some
shock weapons or arrows to first disarm
the bokoblins or he might have snuck in
to steal the weapons first
and then just leave a whole bunch of
korok leaves behind and obviously a
goblin's first instinct when they don't
have a weapon is to search for a weapon
so the
first closest thing is a leaf and
there's a pile of leaves so they just
grab the leaves um and it's just funny
because they don't do any damage so
everybody's it's
the best part is obviously it's a mosh
pit because everybody's attacking each
other accidentally so the gust of wind
obviously
is friendly fire on like it affects
themselves as well so
everybody's just smacking each other
with gusts of wind and leaves and
commons are
flying everywhere and it's super fun so
if you want to try it yourself it's
super easy you could just find a
cobbling camp
and uh sneak in steal their weapons and
then just throw a bunch of leaves on the
ground and then wake them up and that's
their first instinct is to just pretty
much have like a mosh pit with
with korok leaves
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
all right uh so this one is another uh
skew clip with a little bit of humor
added with it
um again it's uh shield clipping or
skews basically
um he must have set it up before he went
into this shrine another interesting
thing about
shrine skew clipping is that these
shield skews when you you know shield
surf onto a hill to get that skew
initially it does matter the cardinal
direction that you're facing so
if you're facing north east south and
west in the overworld it matters in that
direction
on where you can clip into next and in
shrines
you do have to remember that direction
because the shrines also do have
cardinal directions
and you don't really know until you mess
around in the shrine
of which direction things are facing so
he must have set this up outside the
overworld and hyrule field
and then gone into the shrine to do the
skew clip so it's interesting that uh
people are you know utilizing this in
different ways
obviously shrines are pretty useful for
that because you can just go straight to
the wall instead of you know doing the
whole puzzle and worrying about all that
so
all right here's some homework for you
guys this one is very easy and simple
and won't take up too much of your time
glide or slam cancels are a great way to
take on a pack of enemies from above
without killing yourself in the process
normally when you see that juicy
opportunity you remember what happened
last time and opt out of that
but by simply tapping x then y quickly
one after another before hitting the
ground you can get the benefit of both
keeping your landing momentum
and also negating fall damage so again
it's simply tapping x
then why before hitting the ground the
timing is fairly lenient
it's an easy and safe way to start the
fight against some unlucky foes
thanks again for watching if you want to
see the previous episodes of zelda
expert reacts we have the links in the
description and if there are any clips
that you want me to watch submit them to
me by dm on twitter
at renharasaki for everything else on
zelda breath of the wild stay tuned
right here on gamespot
[Music]
you